hello everyone this game was also
suggested to me by a subscriber and it's
the position is from the movie Sherlock
Holmes a game of shadows where Sherlock
Holmes is playing with the black pieces
against professor James Moriarty the
original game the disposition to rise
from is actually Larsson versus
Petrosyan in 1966 I know Monica but in
the original game Larson who plays with
the white pieces actually won the game
but in the movie it's Sherlock Holmes
with the black pieces that wins the game
so it's a bit of a different different
position so this is the position and
while you're welcome to check it out try
and try to find the winning move for
black or some interesting ideas feel
free to pause the video and solve it and
use the duction of course and okay those
of you who managed to solve it I
congratulate you and this is what
actually happens in the movie Sherlock
Holmes plays Queen captures ng3 and more
we already says something like this is a
terrible move you're you're losing your
most valuable piece and Sherlock Holmes
says that well sometimes sacrifices have
to be made so Moriarty captures F
captures from g3 and we have Bishop
captures any any three would check and
before this move was played Maury
already actually left the table and he
says the game is over but roll of homes
in system plays Bishop captures and III
would check and he doesn't play this
move on the table but he just says the
move to Moriarty and then Moriarty looks
at Sherlock Holmes and he says King 2h2
and Sherlock Holmes says rook to h6
check and already Moriarty sees that
something is wrong here he plays Bishop
to h3 and Sherlock Holmes captures
Bishop captures on h3
and now his his threatening all sorts of
discoveries with this Bishop so Moriarty
goes rook to f4
we have rook captures on f4 d captures
on f4 and now Bishop to f2 and the
thread is well very simple it's Bishop
to f1 checkmate and there is no way to
stop this so Moriarty tries a couple of
more moves going to be three tech King -
h8 and I'll capture the pawn on b7 Queen
capture
be seven and here Sherlock Holmes says
Bishop 2f1
discovered check and incidentally mate
so yeah a beautiful checkmating sequence
and this isn't what actually happened in
the original game in the original game
petrosyan didn't accept the Queen
sacrifice immediately and well it took a
different path and it isn't ending
checkmate but I will put the original
game in the description below so you can
check it out and see which game do you
prefer and interestingly this game
between Larson and patron is now called
a Game of Shadows so yeah this is this
is it I do hope you enjoyed it and once
again congratulations total if you can
manage to solve it and as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here and
thank you all for watching I will see
you soon